chlamidia is the most common bacterial
sexually transmitted disease or
infection worldwide it's more common in
women than
men the germs that cause the infection
are tiny bacteria called chlamidia
trachomatis you can catch chyia from an
infected person during vaginal anal or
oral sex and if a pregnant woman has
chlamydia she can pass it to her baby as
the baby moves through the birth canal
during child
birth in your body the infection begins
when the bacteria attached to cells in
the tissue that lines many of your body
cavities called mucosal
epithelium once attached the bacteria
begin to invade this tissue inside the
cell the bacteria start
multiplying when they escape to infect
other cells the bacteria may leave the
cell they came from intact
or the cell may be destroyed as the
bacteria are
released the bacterial infection causes
the body's own immune cells to enter the
tissue this inflames and damages the
tissue as your immune cells try to clear
the
infection unfortunately some of the
bacteria can avoid immune destruction
inside of your
cells the main risk for getting
chlamydia is having unprotected oral
anal or vaginal sex with a person who's
infected you may have a high risk if you
are sexually active and are a young
person especially a young woman don't
always use condoms during sex have more
than one sex partner or are a man who
has sex with men many people have no
symptoms if symptoms do occur they may
not appear until several weeks after
infection
symptoms a woman may have include an
abnormal discharge from the vagina or
birth canal painful sex or a burning
feeling while
urinating a man may have similar
symptoms such as an abnormal discharge
from the penis a burning or itching
feeling at the tip of the penis or a
burning feeling while urinating in both
men and women chlamidia may also infect
the rectum which is the last part of the
large
intestine symptoms of infection in the
rectum may include pain abnormal
discharge or bleeding left untreated the
infection may cause pelvic inflammatory
disease in women this means the
infection is spread to the uterus and
Fallopian tubes pelvic inflammatory
disease can lead to pain in the pelvis
infertility which means not being able
to get pregnant or ectopic pregnancy
meaning a pregnancy that grows outside
of the uterus usually in one of the
fallopian tubes
such a pregnancy cannot be successful if
a woman gives birth while having
untreated chlamydia her baby may be born
early have an eye infection called aamia
neonatorum or have pneumonia in both men
and women untreated chlamidia can cause
reactive arthritis this is painful
swelling in joints as a reaction to the
infection the good news is that
chlamidia can be cured with antibiotics
such as doxycyclin or a ziyin
you may also be prescribed a second
antibiotic such as sep triaxone to treat
possible infection with another sexually
transmitted disease called
ganara people who have chyia are often
infected with gonorrhea at the same time
it's important to know that treatment
may not fix any damage the disease is
already done to your
body you can reduce your risk of getting
chlamidia if you only have sex with one
long-term partner who doesn't have sex
with other people
and who has been tested for chlamydia
and doesn't have it and you can practice
safer sex which means taking steps
before end during sex to prevent you
from getting or spreading chlamydia for
example using condoms correctly every
time you have sex can reduce your
risk the most reliable way to avoid
getting chlamydia is to practice
abstinence this means not having vaginal
anal or oral sex to find out more about
chlamidia talk to your Healthcare
practitioner